son visage est peu connu du grand public
kirilo timoto chef adjoint de
l'administration présidentielle
ukrainienne vient de présenter sa
démission aucune raison officielle n'est
avancée mais son nom est cité dans un
scandale autour de l'utilisation de
voiture de luxe avec lui plusieurs hauts
responsables ont présenté leur démission
ce mardi quelques heures après des
révélations concernant des achats de
provision pour l'armée a pris gonflés
ont été prises certaines pour
aujourd'hui d'autres pour demain
concernant les fonctionnaires de
différents niveaux dans les ministères
et dans les structures du gouvernement
central ainsi que dans les régions et
dans le système d'application de la loi
déjà lundi la police antique corruption
diffusait ses photos de dizaines de
liasses de billets saisies un haut
responsable ministériel avait également
été arrêté soupçonné d'avoir perçu
400000 dollars de peau de vin
le président ukrainien dit vouloir faire
le ménage dans un pays gangrené par la
corruption selon l'ONG Transparency
International l'Ukraine était l'un des
pays les plus corrompus d'Europe avant
la guerre et classé au 122e rang mondial
sur 180 pays en juillet dernier la
présidente de la Commission européenne
appelée Kief a accéléré sa lutte contre
la corruption en jeu l'utilisation des
milliards accordés à l'Ukraine par
l'aide internationale pour reconstruire
le pays